tic merci beaucoup je suppose que vous
avez des souvenirs des beatles et de
paul mccartney
vous savez qu'il est en ce moment même à
cannes il ya en effet la sortie d'un
nouveau cd de 40 chansons et puis l'un
documentaire sur l'histoire du groupe
wings des années 70 michel mompontet
patrick voix l'ont retrouvée pour
entamer un bon festival de cannes rien
de mieux qu'une bonne et rugueuse
première mêlée dans les règles de l'art
et c'est parti dans cet exercice viril
tous les coups sont à peu près permis il
faut être en première ligne avec la
vedette du jour rien qu'à soi
pardon monsieur paul paul on est la pole
une phrase rick pour nous paul bonjour
la france très bien pour monsieur paul a
de beaux souvenirs et nous avec lui bien
sûr et tout ça ça fait un disque et tout
ça ça fait un documentaire dans le
showbiz on le dit rien ne se perd rien
ne se crée lâche bac
nous sommes en 1970 les beatles est
finie et paul lui des primes dans sa
ferme des gosses
les comme pour les hommes bien il ya une
femme encore mieux que lui et qui va
trouver une solution miracle les wings
sa femme linda disparu depuis ne connaît
encore rien à la musique
qu'à cela ne tienne elle apprendra
l'amour peut tout n'est ce pas à paul
elle-même l'admettait au début elle n'y
connaissais rien nous on a voulu
s'amuser s'éclater mais je pense qu'au
delà de ses qualités musicales et
l'internet un esprit fort au sein des
wings une dernière mêlée pour le plaisir
et paul est déjà reparti il ne sera
resté à cannes que le temps d'une
chanson
paul ne part pas paul on t'aime toujours
paul revient